I can't hear
you I need a driver license insurance
please I can't hear you I need your a
window down you're speeding I'm not you
are the speed limit's only 60 you're
going 75 with everybody else right I
can't pull air butle can I get license
insurance I need your driver license
insurance
ma'am do what okay you got an idea on
you okay I need you to step out of the
vehicle
then do what I can't hear
you I can't hear you man can you roll
the window
down
can you open your door so I can hear
you I do have my camera on can I have a
driver license insurance you don't have
it on I do have it on can I have driver
I'll call my supervisor can you can I
have your driver license
insurance okay I'll get one out here for
you
okay
I need your driver license insance I'm
going to run out of
gas driving because she's hungry I get
that but the quicker I get your liced
insurance the quicker we can get out of
here the quicker I get your information
quicker we can get out of here okay she
thank you I'll be right
back yes
ma'am do you want me call an ambulance
for you
would you like me call an ambulance for
you no I need to go get my super would
you like my supervisor he still on the
way okay would you like me to call an
ambulance for you
[Music]
okay zra 7 dispatch my driver's taking
off from me we're going north down
[Music]
bik we're getting on the trim going
eastbound she ran for me she said her
daughter is having a medical episode she
just needs food but she's a golf from I
have her license and
[Music]
insurance
speed we just at 55 right now going to
get on the turn right
[Music]
now your call has next Clos unit to
[Applause]
vacum
a second we're going northbound Easter
she's following all traffic laws we're
going about 55 mph still she stopped at
the red light Easter
[Music]
Memorial she has stopped has no she
stopped for the red light and then it
turned green and she kept going forward
now we're going northbound on Eastern
passing old
[Music]
way call has been
updated up to Easter Memorial fall
traffic 48 M hour turn
[Music]
Memorial your phone has been
updated
no air one today all the
[Music]
pilots 50 mph we're still
has your call has been
[Music]
updated passing PR Lane still going
found on
Memorial low traffic
[Music]
every your phone has been
updated
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
103 he's on BR pulling into the gas
[Music]
station all right we want to thank
Morgan and Morgan for sponsoring this
video you know life's scary minding your
own business when it seems that everyone
and everything no matter where you turn
seems to want to hurt
you okay maybe that was a bit much but
you get the idea the point is you don't
have to feel helpless because Morgan and
Morgan the largest injury law firm in
America is here now before you say oh
great another Law Firm ad first of all
how dare you speak that way of Morgan
and Morgan and second of all you don't
know what makes them special you see
Morgan and Morgan has completely
modernize the personal injury claim
process they make it super easy for you
how well you submit your claim you sign
contracts you upload documents and you
talk to your whole legal Team all on
your phone and you can text your legal
team throughout your case as much as you
want whenever or wherever about whatever
you want now you might be saying that
sounds expensive well here's the kicker
there's no upfront fee no you only pay
them if you win so it's no wonder over 3
million 3 million people call them every
year so if you're injured you can submit
a claim at forthepeople.com laww on
crime or by dialing pound law that's
pound 529 on your
phone why you're F me around put your
hands
on
get out of the car I'm not get away from
me I told you my daughter's have an em
understand and I told you IID request
EMA you cannot from the
TR
get out of the
car get out of the car I need get out of
the car ma'am I need you to send one of
your supervisor officers to the E
Express at Memorial and Bryant your
officer is not getting out her passenger
daughter
trying right now to eat I'm not going to
get out of this I'm not Contracting with
you let go of my hand no ma'am I'm not
getting out with you I'm not going
anywhere with
you I'm not going anywhere with you I
didn't contract with you let go of my
wrist let go I want you to take my
credit card in and go get you something
to eat
go
I need you to come to Memorial and
Bryant you have an Oklahoma City police
officer
arm no he's trying to pull me out of my
own vehicle and
I go let go of me
man let go of me no let let go with me
I'm not my car need get out of the
car I'm not going to get out I'm not
getting out of the car I don't have
to dude I'm not getting
out
Let go please please let go of me
no helping I'm trying to get her food
and was driving the same speed limit as
everyone else expain it to you you took
my license citation you'd be good to go
I'm not doing that I was going to write
a quick citation and you were going to
be good to go dude my
daughter and I understand that and I
offered to call MSA for you I don't want
M we don't contract with MSA I don't
have money for in it it wasn't it was
just to check on her to make sure she
was
okay I have been doing this since she
was five I would like you to let go of
my arm I'm not going to let go of your
arm
man okay well I guess we'll just remain
here because I'm not getting out of my
car and you're not jerking me
out so you can go write your citation
and I'm going to get my daugh we're past
that now so you decided to run I didn't
run man I don't contract with you I gave
you what you asked for and I asked you
to come on on because I have to get her
food I wasn't speeding what's up man oh
you know you know trying to get people
that we actually traffic with you're a
trafficker and you've got me here
breaking my arm cuz you probably traffic
all the dope in here don't
you okay I'm asking you to let go of my
arm I'm asking you to let gois here now
please let go no ma'am I'm not letting
go you're going to get out of the vehic
I'm not getting out you're getting out
of the
V